alright let's dive in with winston-salem
starting off this hour sherry is with us
i Sheree how are you hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve
what's up in your world not a lot
beautiful day here in Carolina
good how can I help well my my mom I'm
trying to figure out how to approach a
situation with her she got herself in
some financial difficulties she's moved
in with me and we agreed to start out
with it you know she paid $200 an out
her cell phone she had the same cell
phone plans on with mine and $200 a
month notes for everything I knew except
for a voyeur food she warned about and
then something come up in February and
she said hey this is you know my car
insurance is going way up from from an
accident which is where I'll just stand
for him he's going to go up like 150
bucks for three months and it's really
right now and I'm like ask me if you
know she could waive that except for the
cell phone I'm like sure I marked with
39 three months and then hold your
mother
58 and why is she living with you when
she had the car accident and then she
went to finance the new car this was
before I knew about you I would have
advised her to do differently she went
finance the new car of course I think
it's like six or seven years I don't own
a new car so I don't know I think it's
like six years at least
why is she living with you because she
couldn't afford the apartment after she
bought the car did she sell the car
no when she won't do it because that's
what I've been suggesting for her to
sustain she needs to move out and live
in the car that's pretty much what I
said and the last discussion I had
didn't go so well so I was trying to
think of a new way to approach it with
her and which now says I guess she's
staying with a friend of hers because
she hadn't been back to the house in
three weeks it's all she moved on had
our little discussion I'm not
technically her stuff is still there
okay she hasn't talked to me so I
thought well I found a way to approach
it but the problem is is that you can't
approach it because she doesn't want to
discuss you the humility of the fact
that she made a huge mistake and you
cannot help people who will not admit
their mistakes
yeah I've made a bunch of mistakes and
some of my admit some of my don't
thank you no and the bottom line is when
you trade your car for and become
homeless that's a bad trade well that's
what I tried to talk to her enough okay
um sell the car I said I'll help you
I'll do anything I can to help you know
and she just won't hear of it
and I'm like well then you need to get a
second job because you can't not pay
rent doesn't matter where you live you
got to pay rent
yeah where you're participating in her
delusion she has a car she can't afford
and you're allowing her to keep it
that's called codependent if you allow
her to live there and I'm not being
snarky but lovingly and firmly you need
to say mom I love you too much to
participate in you doing things that are
going to destroy you and this car is
financially destroying you when you have
to choose between a place to live and a
car payment and you won't sell the car
that's a that's a choice that logical
people don't make it's an illogical
thing and so mom I'm not going to
participate in this I love you too much
you've got to sell the car and if you
don't I can't help you now I'll
participate in helping you if you want
to sell the car and I'll have to help
you with that that's fine but I and help
you get back on your feet and get back
out there but there's a reason to at 58
years old that she's living with you and
it's more than just the car the car is
the last straw that broke the camel's
back she has made a series of bad
financial decisions over the last
several years and she has never looked
in the mirror and taken control of her
life for whatever reason maybe it's a
negative divorce a bad deal maybe it was
the loss of your dad I don't know what
happened in her life but something left
her to where she's not dealing with life
and this car is the last time that we
get that it's the latest version of her
not dealing with her life because
otherwise she wouldn't be 58 and
completely penniless there's a lot of
bad things happen to people but it's how
you react when something happens to you
that that keeps you in or out of these
situations so I hope that helps you I
think you're doing the right thing
you're not crazy and you're not mean and
you don't hate your mom as a matter of
fact if you participate in her
continuing to own that car in a sense
you're doing her harm
you need to continue to look at it that
way
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you